on
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur france 3 en
bourgogne et en franche comté pour cette
émission spéciale au lendemain du
premier tour des élections législatives
comment ont voté les électeurs en région
et comment les partis politiques
s'organisent en vue du second tour
on analysera la situation politique avec
catherine aime syrie et lilian melet et
puis place au débat dans cette émission
avec ceux qui ont accepté cet exercice
aujourd'hui alain chrétien maire de
vesoul député sortant suppléant battu en
haute-saône membres des républicains
tendance bruno le maire alexandre amaury
une porte parole de la france insoumise
maxime thiébaut candidats battus en
saône et loire pour le front national
est avec nous en direct de besançon
michel neugnot vice président ps du
conseil régional et jean louis fousseret
maire de besançon pour la république en
marche en provenance du ps je précise
puisque en direct de paris nous
rejoindrons jean-baptiste lemoyne
sénateur de l'yonne pour la république
en marche mais en provenance des
républicains alors comme au niveau
national la république en marche et le
modem sont arrivés en tête des suffrages
des électeurs en bourgogne franche comté
c'est simple les candidats de la
majorité présidentielle sont qualifiés
dans toutes les circonscriptions de
bourgogne franche comté ils sont même en
tête dans 24 des 27 circonscriptions
exemple de cette vague macron dans notre
région dans la première circonscription
du territoire de belfort avec un ancien
ump a ensuite passé au modem christophe
grudler qui se présente aussi avec
l'étiquette la république est en marche
il est arrivé hier vous le voyez en tête
avec près de 32% des voix loin devant le
candidat et liliane boucard sofiane
al-issaoui de nicole il peut savourer sa
victoire
avec près de 32% des voix christophe
grudler arrive largement en tête
il devance de lille
yanbu car un candidat soutenu par son
rival historique un certain damien
meslot
quelques heures plus tôt le candidat
arrive dans son bureau de vote
bonjour et de tous les bulletins ils
évitent soigneusement d'en sélectionner
certains mais à cette heure-là
christophe grudler là sur les querelles
politiques
c'est du passé moi je suis toujours là
pour faire du positif cette campagne on
l'a fait sur du positif parce qu'on
croit à quelque chose on croit qu'on
peut apporter des idées pour la
circonscription le département et donc
je laisse de côté les règlements de
comptes politiciens c'est pas pour moi à
18 heures les bureaux de vote ont fermé
le candidat patiente en famille et avec
ses équipes
les yeux rivés sur les résultats qui
tombent donc tu restes en ligne etc
nicolas pour que tu puisses te donner à
mesure ce qu'il a en fait au moment du
dépouillement christophe grudler ce ses
favoris mais à mesure qu'ils découvrent
les résultats il prend conscience de la
puissance de la vague en marche ou le
carton rouge est si on à autre on a 80
voix d'avancé sur le deuxième comme l'a
fait remarquer on se connaît tous et
déjà le candidat s'attend à ce que la
bataille menée par l'actuel député maire
de belfort soit rude
moi je connaisse la journée ces
techniques dur interne blindés mobiliser
nombreux
mobiliser ses troupes pour la dernière
ligne droite avec un seul objectif en
tête ici même
dimanche prochain pour la victoire
alors on vient de voir ce qui s'est
passé dans le territoire de belfort vous
allez nous dire catherine aime dire ici
c'est représentatif de ce qui s'est
passé en france comptait hier soir et
bien tout à fait en effet la république
en marche c'est le parti grand vainqueur
de cette élection législative en franche
comté
tous les candidats macro nice sont
qualifiés pour le second tour
alors ils sont opposés soit à des
candidats républicains c'est le cas dans
cette circonscription soit au candidat
frontiste
c'est le cas dans trois circonscriptions
dans l'es2 de haute saône est également
dans le pays de montbéliard où frédéric
barbier le député socialiste sortant qui
a aussi l'investiture en marche
affrontera sophie montel du front
national à noter la situation de
besançon qui bien particulière nous
trouvons en effet un duel la république
en marche ps barbara romagnan la députée
socialiste feront d'eux est en
ballottage très défavorable il a
totalisé 16 % des suffrages face à la ma
chronique
fanette charvier presque 30% des voix et
puis toujours à besançon un autre cas
l'autre député sortant eric alauzet
écologistes qui n'a eu l'investiture il
les a perdus ni d'europe écologie les
verts ni du parti socialiste et qu'il
n'avait pas réussi à obtenir
l'investiture en marche réalise tout de
même le meilleur score des députés
sortants avec plus de 42 % des voix loin
devant le républicain ludovic fagots 21%
merci catherine pour ses premiers
éléments alors l'un des effets
importants de ce premier tour c'est la
débâcle du parti socialiste légitimiste
ou frondeurs sont presque tous à la même
enseigne et même dans les fiefs
historiques comme le très mitterrandien
morvan où le ps sortant christian paul
est largement distancé par patrice
perron le candidat de la république en
marche
johan albrecht tente à césar
qualification de justesse pour christian
paul
avec 18,2 pour cent des bulletins le
député sortant arrive deuxième de ce
premier tour et résiste tant bien que
mal à la déroute socialiste
nous avons aujourd'hui fait mentir les
sondages je serai avec stéphane
bénédicte mon suppléant au second tour
de cette élection législative et je vais
évidemment préparé ce second tout dans
un esprit de très large rassemblement
rassemblement des forces de gauche bien
sûr mais est bien au delà de tous les
nivernais qui veulent à l'assemblée
nationale un député utile efficace
expérimentés et combatif car le scrutin
s'annonçait difficile pour le chef de
file des frondeurs prix entre le succès
annoncé de patrice perron quand la
république en marche et la montée du fn
à la présidentielle 41% des votes pour
marine le pen au deuxième tour
monsieur christian paul 240 voix soit 43
%
monsieur harold de blanot 75 voix soit
13 % mais les électeurs du front
national ne se sont pas déplacés hier
avec 15,1 pour cent des suffrages sur la
circonscription à rolle de blanot
mobilise moins de voix que le candidat
frontiste en 2012
un résultat dont s'est réjoui patrice
perron j'arrive en tête respectivement
sur cette deuxième circonscription de la
nièvre
on s'oriente donc sur un gun avec avec
christian paul ce qui me fait surtout
plaisir c'est le fait de voir le front
national recule et je pense que c'est
une belle chose pour cette 2e
circonscription qui en avaient souffert
lors de l'élection présidentielle sur
les terres de françois mitterrand le
candidat de la république en marche a
réuni deux fois plus de suffrages que
les députés sortants socialistes alors
lilian melet on a découvert hier soir
une bourgogne totalement marche
ah oui ça n'est pas un raccourci puisque
en bourgogne sur les 15 circonscriptions
les 15 candidats dans marche sont en
tête du premier tour
c'était attendu dans certaines
circonscriptions mais l'ampleur du
phénomène situe la force de la vague
pour la bourgogne très socialiste en
2012 avec dix députés sur 15 c'est donc
une révolution puisque deux socialistes
seulement accède au 2e tour les deux
sortants christian paul ont la vue et
cécile untermaier mais tous deux sont en
position défavorable
deuxième force nationale de ces
législatives la droite est donc la
deuxième force bourguignonne de ce
premier tour dix candidats se sont
qualifiés mais la dynamique clairement
leur fait défaut
et comme dans toute la france le front
national a clairement raté ce premier
tour des législatives en bourgogne pour
faire simple selon les circonscriptions
le parti a perdu entre la moitié et les
deux tiers des voix de marine le pen de
la présidentielle il y aura donc trois
candidats dans des 2e tour en côte d'or
dans la nièvre et surtout dans le nord
de l'yonne mais jamais en position
réellement favorable
merci lilian on va rejoindre en direct
de paris jean baptiste lemoyne sénateur
de l'yonne pour la république en marche
en provenance je le disais des
républicains vous vous dites aujourd'hui
que vous avez fait le bon choix
je suis heureux effectivement d'avoir
été parmi les précurseurs mais heureux
pour le pays parce que aujourd'hui on
voit que les français eh bien ils sont
dans la cohérence
il souhaite on l'a vu donner une
majorité stable
ford je crois solide au président de la
république au premier ministre edouard
philippe
et tout ça pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
vous savez bien ce programme ce
programme sur lequel emmanuel macron été
élu et qui est un programme je crois à
porter à la fois 2 allée de liberté
retrouvée pour les artisans les
commerçants les agriculteurs et en même
temps aussi avec la création de
nouvelles protections avec par exemple
en les rendant éligibles à l'assurance
chômage c'est indépendant en recrutant
dix mille policiers et gendarmes bref
jean baptiste équilibré jean-baptiste
lemoyne il y à melay à dijon est-ce que
c'est pas trop ce qui se profile est ce
que c'est une chambre aussi majoritaire
qui laissera en réalité pas de place au
débat et ce qui a pas le risque par
exemple que le débat se déplace ailleurs
dans le pays et de façon peut être
difficile à gérer
je ne crois pas vous savez la force dans
marche c'est de réunir d'unir des femmes
et des hommes qui ont des sensibilités
qui parfois peuvent être différentes
voyez je viens des républicains d'autres
viennent de la social-démocratie du
centre mais quelles que soient nos
parcours par le passé nous avons une
conviction c'est que nous regardons dans
la même direction et nous avons des
réponses identiques pour sortir le pays
de l'ornière
dans le département de l'yonne on le
voit très bien avec trois candidats en
marche
arrivé en tête vous voyez quelqu'un qui
est issu de la gauche comme jean yves
caullet quelqu'un qui est issu du centre
comme michel crouzet est quelqu'un qui a
de la société civile paulo da silva
médecin maire rural
eh bien nous avons besoin de ces trois
talents de ces trois profils dont les
parcours sont différents mais qui
souhaite une chose c'est faire réussir
l'yonne faire réussir la france en finir
avec une fatalité
la fatalité d'un chômage de masse la
fatalité peut-être d'une crainte par
rapport à la sécurité
eh bien nous nous apportons des réponses
concrètes vous je crois que la marque de
fabrique de l macron c'est l'efficacité
on a comparé à sont pas des anciens
clients
merci jean baptiste lemoyne en direct de
paris sénateur de l'yonne alors alain
chrétien jean baptiste lemoyne ça fait
un moment qu'il a franchi le rubicon
vous le le mérite
vous auriez pu aussi rejoindre plus
directement emmanuel macron vous avez
préféré vous présenter sans étiquette
derrière votre candidat puisque vous
étiez suppléant vous n'avez pas souhaité
vous représenter en tant que candidat
est ce que vous regrettez pas
aujourd'hui de ne pas avoir pris une
étiquette en marre d'avoir essayé de la
voir
je connais bien jean baptiste lemoyne
c'est un ami de longue date c'est je
salue son courage politique
je crois qu'il faut aussi raison garder
et rester dans sa famille politique je
suis républicain j'ai grandi en
politique avec ma famille l'est
républicain je suis peiné de voir ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui une famille
boursouflé de de haine de rancoeur de
règlements de comptes on l'a vu dans ma
circonscription en haute saône et je
crains fort que le républicain dans les
semaines qui viennent explose parce
qu'on n'a plus grand chose à faire
ensemble
malheureusement il faut vraiment qu'on
se remette en cause j'aime ma famille
politique on a des choses à dire des
valeurs à défendre
sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est une guerre
d'égos et de règlement de comptes après
le fiasco de françois fillon
ça veut dire que les républicains c'est
terminé ou alors il ya un petit noyau
qui va rester aux républicains et
d'autres comme vous vous pouvez
peut-être partir du parc mais on le voit
bien qu'on ose des chronos se dire que
chez makro ya des bonnes choses on se
fait mais alors descendre par certains
républicains
il ya un sectarisme qui est en train de
monter dans ce parti que moi je ne
supporte plus
je demande aux républicains du respect y
compris dans leur propre famille
politique
sinon on va à la catastrophe
effectivement bruno le maire est mise
l'économie et des finances j'en suis
fier c'est un ami je suis heureux qu'ils
puissent contribuer à la réussite de la
france mais il était républicain et nous
partageons beaucoup de choses ensemble
moi j'entends que vous signez en marche
demain non je ne suis pas en marche
comme série solaire je me suis pas en
marche mais je veux que ça marche
contrairement à ceux qui veulent tout
bloquer et qui veulent l'échec de la
france aujourd'hui un poste qui veulent
soit aussi la non c'est ce qu'ils
veulent la réussite du pays est vraiment
je veux la réussite du pays mais aussi
de ma famille politique c'est
conciliables alors on évoquait la
débâcle du parti socialiste on va
rejoindre michel neugnot
du côté de besançon michel neugnot
vous aussi vous vous faites quoi
aujourd'hui vous compter les points vous
comptez constater les dégâts et vous
vous dites comment on va se relever ou
bien vous avez déjà signé l'arrêt de
mort comme beaucoup un du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui dans les médias
la vague était très forte
l épargner aucun des partis existants ou
naissants et effectivement le parti
socialiste est très atteint c'est une
débâcle
on ne se comptera pas du fait que entre
benoît hamon 6,36 et les 10% que l'on a
récupéré il ya une légère progression
mais pour autant le mal était profond il
été ressenti au premier tour des
présidentielles par l'élimination
et contrairement à ce que certains
pensaient que l'on était frondeur ou pas
qui ont été plus à droite ou à gauche du
parti shass a dit c'est tout l'été
emporté loup il faut que je n'étais pas
michel deniau
c'est le quinquennat c'est le bilan d'un
quinquennat raté c'est un parti qui
sépare renouvelée qui n'a pas proposé
d'idées nouvelles vous est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous essayez de
comprendre sa nettement
honnêtement le bilan du quinquennat a
été pour très peu dans la campagne
électorale parce que personne ne l'a
défendu personne ne liant défendu il va
s'apprécier au fil du temps avec les
ombres et les lumières ce que l'on peut
dire c'est que la france
livrée par françois hollande est dans un
meilleur état que celles qu'il a trouvé
en 2012 mais ça c'est l'histoire tout
faire et qui va le dire où vous êtes à
côté de jean louis fousseret on
l'entendra tout à l'heure mais est-ce
que vous lui dites ça aujourd'hui est ce
que est ce que vous pensez que les
anciens camarades qui ont rejoint en
mars selon son responsable
non non non ceux qui sont responsables
c'est pas ce qu'ils ont fait leurs choix
personnels ceux qui sont responsables et
bien c'est effectivement l'incapacité
que l'on a eu à travailler groupe est à
revoir les pratiques à avoir un parti
socialiste plus à l'écouté
c'est cela le problème et le problème
qui se pose maintenant c'est de savoir
si entre le maquereau 10 mhz appelons le
comme ça et la france a soumises et il
ya une place ou non pour la social
démocratie et c'est tout le travail que
l'on va avoir à faire
je souhaite qu'il ya un travail qui se
fasse le plus rapidement possible avec
un rond congrès de refondation on est
dans l'état clos maintenant du rêve
sefyu et nécessité donc de faire une
sorte de deux congrès d'epinay dans
d'autres formes mais pour refonder parce
que je pense profondément
pour répondre à votre de spéciale qui
lie à un une voie entre le maquereau
nisme et droite et gauche et on va là
valence exprimé michel lagneaux jean
louis fousseret le maire de besançon
quatrième dirais oui jean louis
fousseret bonjour donc je rappelle que
vous êtes maire de besançon président de
l'agglomération vous êtes socialiste et
vous avez donc opté pour emmanuel macron
lié à déjà plus d'un an donc vous êtes
macro nist là quand on voit la majorité
qui se dessine est-ce qu'il ya pas un
risque qu'il y ait d'un côté des
néophytes et de l'autre des recyclés je
pense maman franche comté il ya certains
recyclé dont qui ont un petit peu plus
de bouteille et qu'on risque d'avoir une
un fossé entre ces deux personnes ce qui
laisserait la place à excusez moi
l'expression ou des frondeurs dans cette
majorité trop large ou alors beaucoup de
place aux technocrates non pas du tout
je crois que le résultat de ce vote
c'est aussi la volonté des françaises et
des français
de faire en sorte effectivement les
visages nouveaux des pratiques nouvelles
non je crois que michel leniaud le
disais je crois que les partis
politiques traditionnels
ils n'ont pas compris ils sont restés
sur leur vieux schémas leurs schémas
traditionnels
il faut que les français les français
retrouvent confiance avec les boutiques
il faut changer les choses et pour cela
il faut que des visages nouveaux avec
des visages expérimentés emmanuel macron
notre président l'a dit dès le départ
elle nouvelle assemblée il y aura 50 %
de personnes nouvelles et d'autres qui
sont plus expérimentés et on va
apprendre parce que justement ces
députés jean louis fousseret excusez-moi
de vous interrompre est ce que justement
ces députés totalement néophyte
ce ne seront pas des députés godillots
qui lèveront la main quand il faut qu'on
leur dira de vela membres non non non
d'abord ce ne sont pas des n'est
peut-être néophyte en politique
so personnes qui viennent du monde de
l'entreprise de la vie associative qui
ont une expérience qui est pas forcément
élections'' politique mais qui ont une
véritable expérience et puis vous savez
il ya quelques temps le grand sujet
c'était est-ce que macro il aura une
majorité pour gouverner
on avait peur pour lui qui n'est pas
cette majorité aujourd'hui le souci
c'est est-ce qu'elle n'est pas trop
forte je crois qu'il faut quand même
quelques pas ressenti s'entendre
là-dessus il y à une perte de confiance
énorme des françaises et français envers
les politiques c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que la moitié des électeurs ne se sont
pas ne sont pas déplacés alors
aujourd'hui il faut donner à notre
président effectivement des moyens pour
que le débat ait lieu bien sûr il a dit
le débat ait lieu à l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi le puisse mettre en
place rapidement très rapidement car il
ya peu de tout cela les réformes qui ont
offert ce que la france va changer
merci à jean louis fousseret pour cette
première intervention et il y en a qui
ne veulent pas aider les lions menaient
sur ce plateau le président de la
république assez classique alexandrine a
acquiescé quand j'ai dit bilan du
quinquennat
les acteurs michelle onyewu 10 en fait
ça a pas joué le bilan du quinquennat
parce que tu vois n'y avait personne
pour le défendre
c'est quoi votre point de vue je pense
que le bilan il a joué sur sur deux
choses déjà sur la désaffection
vis-à-vis du
des candidats socialistes bien entendu
mais aussi et malheureusement je pense
que dans le regret de tous aussi sur
l'abstention
je pense que le quinquennat qui a eu
lieu les cinq dernières années où on
avait promis des choses et ils n'ont pas
été tenues je pense que ça ça joue
énormément aussi dans la désaffection
des français pour le vote donc il ya une
double une double influence du cac et
les affections législatif après la
présidentielle sa date de 2002 peu de
choses près et les élections après
élections la participation elle est en
baisse c'est aussi les ampoules sont en
baisse c'est aussi le problème de
l'inversion du calendrier en effet qui a
eu lieu depuis le début des années 2000
où hélas on devrait dire que tous les
canards ont été ratées c'est pour ce nom
je le pense sur pas mal d'aspects en
tout cas après l'inversion du calendrier
ayant joué ça à transformer aussi
l'assemblée nationale comme une
véritable chambre d'enregistrement
au final j'entendais tout à l'heure
monsieur fousseret qui disait que le
débat devrait avoir lieu à l'assemblée
nationale mais il n'aura pas lieu
puisque emmanuel macron malgré
l'assemblée qui serait apparemment
pléthorique pour lui continue quand même
de vouloir passer des réformes par
ordonnance donc aucun débat n'aura lieu
alors même qu'il a la majorité issue et
maureen malgré tout aucun de vos
candidats france insoumise alors que
jean luc mélenchon est arrivé en
troisième position
aucun nouveau candidat ne s'est
qualifiée pour le deuxième tour non mais
ça plaît voilà en bourgogne franche
comté
donc vous avez crâne un vrai problème de
positionnement dans l'opposition je
pense qu'on en est alors on est passé
pas loin sur énormément d'endroits et
c'est vrai que c'est ce que meilleur
jour disait déjà pour le deuxième tour
mais ça me met pas ce que c'est vrai je
prends l'exemple par exemple sur la
première circonscription de côte-d'or où
ça s'est joué à 842 voix voyez c'est
c'est quelque chose qui réagiront
ensuite maxime qu'elle pense que c'est
que cette opposition s'exprime dans la
rue
le risque c'est sa semelle sexuelle
attendait monocolore avec des macros
nist qui effectivement n'y connaissent
rien il faut se le dire sont des gens
qui à trois semaines ne connaissez rien
en politique on leur a collé l'étiquette
macro et ils ont été élus moi j'en
connais beaucoup et il y aura beaucoup
de désillusion parce que deux députés
c'est parce qu'on croit c'est parce
qu'on croit camp de l'opposition c'est
cause toujours
et dans la majorité t'as rien à dire
donc ils vont être très déçu je le pense
alors je le disais en présentation on
peut dire élections légistatives raté
pour le front national je prenais un
exemple de certaines circonscriptions
bourguignonne entre la moitié et les
deux tiers des voix de marine le pen de
la présidentielle perdue
il se passe quoi sur ces législatives
est ce que c'est que votre électorat
s'en désintéressent qui considère que
c'était perdu ou qu' il ya des choses
internes vous allez dire que je vous
ressort ce que je vous ai dit hier sur
un score électoral
mais il ya des choses internes qui ont
froid en vacances n'a pas changé au
front national qui sont en train de
poser souci
non mais attendez quand vous regardez
quand même les résultats vous avez 50 %
de la population qui n'est pas allé
voter
donc on peut pas comparer par rapport à
la présidentielle et aux raisons qui
avaient plus quand vous regardez leur
front national ne sont pas allés voter
que dans d'autres pas ça c'est certain
on en parlait hier il ya eu un défaut de
mobilisation dans le camp des patriotes
mais je pense au fait que tout le monde
se voyait gagnant monsieur macron pour
l'élection législative et moi je regarde
à l'intérieur je rappelle que vous
suivez enfin et pour les palmiers c'est
pas les distensions vous avez des
dissensions partout et chez nous tout va
bien on est dans une refonte on est en
train de réformer le mouvement non je
pense qu'en fait les gens ont été
démobilisés les gens ont été démobilisés
c'est tout et quand je regarde par
rapport en 2012 au premier tour des
élections législatives les républicains
ump ont divisé par deux le nombre de
voix le ps a divisé par sept
et nous nous avons perdu 500 mille voix
donc globalement on a quand même un
socle qui est en train de se constituer
et là on rentre dans une nouvelle bpoc
bipolarisation de la vie politique avec
d'un côté les mondialistes
monsieur macron et tous ses copains et
de l'autre les patriotes qui sont en
train de se réformer
alors juste une un chiffre puisque vous
citer des chiffres en bourgogne franche
comté vous avez perdu entre premier tour
de la présidentielle le premier tour des
législatives hier soir plus de 200 mille
voix ce n'est pas comparable à cause de
l'abstention
mais ce qu'on sait pas comparable vous
ne jouez pas sur la même échelle
donc prenez des chiffres comparables
alors après les candidats front national
qui n'ont pas fait campagne complètement
inconnu regardez les hans adam gabrel je
n'ai jamais vu et puis elle faire j'ai
pu 30%
donc ça n'a rien à voir des gens de sa
candidate dans le territoire de belfort
on ne l'a jamais vu dans ce département
j'ai des échos mais donc quand vous
parlez de changements dans le parti dont
au front national
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut que
vous alliez faire un peu plus de rigueur
un peu plus de professionnalisation je
pense qu'il faut moi je suis pour un
changement de nom et je suis pour
rassembler davantage je pense
aujourd'hui que le mouvement doit avoir
un peu plus de monde rassemblé davantage
donc oui est ce que vous espérez les
conséquences de ce qu alain chrétien
évoquait alors à l'autre bord de ce qu
alain chrétien évoqué mais si les
républicains explose est ce que vous
vous espérez clairement récupérer une
partie de ce parti pour manger quelque
chose retrouver les oreilles de ses
soins médicaux j'espère retrouver les
souverainistes alain sept jeux on
s'entend bien parce qu'en 2012
tu es venu soutenir contre le tsg à
l'assemblée nationale le fait notre
assemblée nationale ne soit pas sous la
mainmise de bruxelles
donc oui naturellement on peut tendre la
main à des républicains qui sont
souverainistes qui sont passés de macron
là c'est pas le même sujet mais non je
pense qu'aujourd'hui tout est dans le
brouillard
il ya plus d'idéologie ça c'est sûr y'a
pus dogmatisme il ya plus de certitudes
il faut avoir conscience de ça que ce
qu'ils disent j'ai raison contre tous
les autres ils ont tort ça c'est celle
que chez les républicains
tant qu'on dira j'ai raison tous les
autres ont tort eh bien on va se planter
il faut voir l'essence de besançon pour
analyser la situation de la gauche les
scores réalisés dans la ville sont sans
appel et comme un symbole le kursaal
plus j'ai de la gauche était
désespérément vides hier chronique d'une
mort annoncée avec stéphanie bourgeot et
david martin 20 heures ils sont venus
timidement en très petit comité
la plupart sans y croire juste pour
mesurer la casse la république en marche
piétine tout sur son passage
le camp socialiste est dévasté hollande
réussi
exactement comme après guy mollet c'est
exactement pareil après guillemot là il
y avait tant de réactions ses débuts
j'avais de fer qu'ils étaient encore
hier
cette nuit une censure
les résultats sont sans appel
au fil des circonscriptions l'hémorragie
n'épargne personne pas même les
frondeurs c'est un effondrement mais
vous constaterez que je suis néanmoins
au deuxième tour il y en a pas tant que
ça quand dans quelques semaines ou
quelques mois
on va se rendre compte qu'en fait les
députés qui sont élus à l'assemblée
nationale avale tout quoi que ce soit
parce qu'en plus le programme des
candidats en marche c'est d'aider le
président macro enfin je rappelle que
les parlementaires ils sont vraiment là
pour représenter le peuple on ne sait
pas ce qu'ils vont faire
et pour ce qu'on sait c'est quand même
assez dangereux 21h à besançon le
kursaal se vide en même temps que les
bancs ps de l'assemblée nationale
il y a le feu à la maison gauche il va
falloir sauver les meubles et l'héritage
aujourd'hui les forces d'avenir c'est
france a soumise c'est nous qui
représente leur présentons en fait ben
les fondamentaux d'une politique de
progrès humanistes sociales et aux
logiques c'est vraiment ça qu'on défende
etc
ça sera la force qui va compter demain
je pense qu'il ya des socialistes qui
sont sur des vraies bad socialiste sur
lesquels je pense qu'on peut construire
un certain nombre de choses ensemble
il va falloir se rassembler avec des
verres de france a soumises des
socialistes des communistes et je le dit
d'une façon plus large la société civile
pour reconstruire une véritable gauche
et donner de la perspective à nos
concitoyens rassembler les miettes quand
d'autres sa slate à la table des
vainqueurs de nouveaux visages
concentrés sur l'objectif
je regarde pas trop si c'est ce qui se
fait à côté je suis vraiment là pour
porter le projet des manuels macouin et
on est là vraiment pour travailler pour
travailler là dessus
après on est pas mal on n'est pas fermés
au dialogue 22 heures
le kursaal et désert la république est
en marche et elle déchire jusqu'au
paysage politique
elle déchire peut-être un peu jean louis
fousseret de quelque chose que vous avez
construit ces dernières années autour de
la gauche a besoin son nom quand même
oui bien sûr ce que je regrette surtout
c'est que je le disais tout à l'heure
que le les partis traditionnels n'ai pas
compris qu'il fallait changer qu'il soit
resté aveugle et sur des schémas
traditionnels
maintenant je crois qu'il a une grande
volonté effectivement de faire les
choses autrement de voir des visages 9
de concevoir la politique autrement
dans le camp des progressistes ce que
nous nous sommes pour une vision
différente
vous savez le problème des manuels
macron c'est aussi de libérer de
protéger d'avancé et j'entends bien ce
que disent et haley qui tient tout à nos
jeunes non j'ai pas au développement
jean louis fousseret allemande de
développer le programme d' emmanuel
macron qu'on a déjà entendu pendant
toute l'élection présidentielle je
voudrais savoir ce que ce que je
voudrais savoir en face de vous vous
avez un socialiste qui s'appelle michel
neugnot
c'est un partenaire c'est tant mieux me
comment vous le qualifiez de toute façon
c'est certainement pas un ennemi c'est
un partenaire parce que au-delà de ces
élections législatives avec michel nous
nous allons continuer à travailler entre
autres au niveau de la delà de la grande
région moi je suis pas la grande région
mais dans les collectivités
territoriales comment ça va se passer
entre vous entre les en marche entre les
socialistes entre le pc avec les tc vous
avez dans votre majorité
les arrageois également les ché alors je
suis vous aimeriez que nous puissions
nous taper dessus mais ça ne sera pas le
cas j'ai depuis le départ dit comment je
concevais les choses les affaires
nationales chacun ses positions moi je
me suis engagé en 2014 sur un programme
vise à vis des bisontines et des
bisontins et jusqu'en 2020 effectivement
nous appliquerons ligne ali mohamoud ce
programme d'une hyundai mis en place en
2014 dollars alors ça peut peut-être des
pleins on pourrait peut-être souhaité
qu'il y ait entre parenthèses de la
bagarre entre nous ça ne sera pas le cas
je ne vais pas dévié de ne lui mette la
ligne que j'ai proposé donc au bisontine
aux byzantins en 2014 je continuerai à
travailler avec michel hunault on a
forcément envie d'entendre michel
l'oignon et et pour prolonger géant
vient de sonder à michel neugnot
s'ils regrettent pas que finalement des
gens proches parce qu'on voit bien que
vous êtes proche et pas réussi à
s'entendre et d'ailleurs est ce que
c'est la faute des manuels macron est-ce
que voilà michel neugnot vous regrettez
ça vous qui ait pas eu de d'accord et de
pacte de non agression
quand on veut se projeter dans l'avenir
pour jamais avoir de regret sur le passé
pour prendre des choses telles qu'elles
sont tous on a eu dans la vie politique
à gauche comme à droite
des trajectoires différentes des points
de rencontre des points de divergence
la difficulté c'est que dans le parti
socialiste on n'a pas pu continuer à
réussir une synthèse dynamique s'adapte
à la situation à la modernité du moment
donc ce qui reste à construire
moi je pense que le maquereau nisme va
vivre sa vie c est droite et gauche
on va voir ce que cela donne avec le
marc cendrier réseau avec une assemblée
forte ce qui nous rapproche des manuels
du mâcon scelleront c'est ce qui nous
éloigne de la france insoumise
par contre nous pensons je pense
personnellement qu'il va falloir
construire à partir de nos forces nos
forces sont des élus dans les communes
dans les départements dans les régions
et montrer l'exemple et avancer à partir
de cela je crois qu'il va voir il y a
une place entre la social entre le
maquereau ni ce et droite et gauche qui
est l'artiste un grand succès et la
france a soumise le sait s'est élevé
cela que le parti socialiste devra
porter l'avenir le fus faut le bon c'est
vrai le droite
oui c'est pas le droite et gauche le
prodiss c'est le camp du progrès
viennent nous rejoindre tous et tous
ceux qui veulent que la france retrouve
de la vigueur retrouvée de l'optimisme
retrouve de loin si tu perds mais je
sais je me mêle la marque de fabrique
c'est pas le mini 2 pérou c'est le et et
et on voit bien qu'il y a un premier
ministre et à certaines 2012 et marc à
droite d'autres marques à gauche et on
verrait des conservateurs de droite et
aussi des concerts et des progressions
de droit je précise que je ne présage
pas du tout de l'avenir
cuche est sur un certain de dossiers
régionaux je suis plutôt dans le camp du
progrès et j'espère même de répondre aux
besoins de nos concitoyens au quotidien
parce que c'est comme cela qu'on
n'arrivera à redonner goût à la
politique et le dawning durablement donc
ce travail à faire par contre reste
toujours cette problématique et droite
et gauche et puis aussi l'engagement qui
a été pris sur l'honneur par tous les
candidats de voter tous les textes
proposés
le duo merci on voit qu'avec jean louis
fousseret vous êtes quand même
relativement d'accord même s'il ya j'ai
bien compris
des points de désaccord va s'intéresser
à une circonscription qui était tenue
par la droite du côté de montbard et
châtillon dans la 4e circonscription de
côte-d'or détenue par françois sauvadet
depuis 24 ans
la candidate en marche est aussi arrivé
en tête mais c'est le plus petit score
du département la droite espère
conserver cette circonscription alors
que la bataille entre les deux rivaux de
droite s'est jouée finalement à un
cheveu christophe taris dalila iberraken
il s'en est fallu d'un souffle pour que
l'héritier désigné de françois sauvadet
investi par l'ue dei et les républicains
ne passent à la trappe
charles barrière de vence le dissident
hubert brigand de 33 voix seulement
alors forcément dans le camp barrière
hier soir il y avait du soulagement mais
aussi de l'ambition car les comptes ont
été vite fait en ajoutant leurs scores
la droite serait devant la candidate en
marche
encore faut-il se rassembler je
comprends que pour hubert brigand ce
soir la situation soit soit très
difficile très difficile à vivre parce
qu'encore une fois je pense qu'il a fait
une très belle campagne mais je pense
que le le résultat est là et je pense
que personne ne comprendrait et encore
moins ses électeurs qui est pas de
rassemblement de tout tout le camp de la
droite et du centre et même au delà du
côté de châtillon fief d'hubert brigand
en a longtemps cru tenir les premiers
rôles
fort de ce corps quasi majoritaire dans
tout le pays châtillonnais
mais finalement dépasser sur le fil il
devra se contenter d'un rôle d'arbitré
car son choix n'est pas encore arrêté
attendez un fraudeur garder un petit peu
avec toute mon équipe
ils vont analyser un petit peu les
déclarations des uns des autres ils vont
regarder un petit peu ce qu'a écrit
françois sauvadet
ces déclarations la presse ces courriers
on va regarder un petit peu en marche et
c'est bon mais ça on verra ça dans un
deuxième temps un frein analyses
précises pour pouvoir se prononcer les
reports des familles loi du fn bien plus
bas qu'à la présidentielle et des 6000
des forces de gauche sont aussi
déterminants
la majorité départementale et par
ricochet françois sauvadet joueront gros
sur cette 4e circonscription alors à
droite toujours on a un peu la gueule de
bois ce matin en haute saône exit les
candidats dans les deux circonscriptions
celle de vesoul la guerre est
officiellement déclarée entre le député
maire sortant qui est avec nous à la
chrétien et le sénateur et l'ère alain
joyandet chacun soutenait d'ailleurs un
candidat différent pour y voir plus
clair le reportage de maxime villers
îlots et philippe arvel la première
circonscription de haute saône n'a pas
échappé allait l'emporter par la
république en marche
barbara besson malo candidate investie
par le mouvement des manuels macron se
prépare à affronter léonie cugnaux du
front national au second tour
mais au delà de ce constat c'est
l'identité même de cette circonscription
qui a été bouleversée y ait pas de
candidat de droite second tour alors que
les républicains il y avait réalisé de
très bons scores jusque là la
conséquence d'une guerre fratricide
entre dimitri dussault assistant
parlementaire d'alain joyandet et marie
breton
la suppléante du candidat sortant et
maire de vesoul alain chrétien qui était
très colère hier soir on se rend bien
compte qu'il ya quelque chose de à
droite qui ne marche plus en haute saône
donc j'appelle aujourd'hui à la
démission d'alain joyandet de son poste
de secrétaire départemental des
républicains en haute saône
j'appelle à une refondation complète de
la droite parce que si on continue comme
ça
après avoir perdu les régionales je vous
rappelle que alain joyandet qui était
tête de liste aux régionales a fait le
pire score c'est ce score là qui nous a
fait perdre la région
il a tenté de faire perdre ma première
adjointe aux cantonales en 2015
donc maintenant ça suffit pour le
candidat investi par les instances
parisiennes des républicains la défaite
est amère mais elle doit être considérée
à l'aune des résultats obtenus pas aussi
mauvais qu'on a bien voulu le laisser
entendre
j'ai fait un tour particulièrement
honorable en cinq semaines j'ai obtenu
12 5% des suffrages exprimés ce soir
pour regard du contexte national du
contexte local
aida dissidente incarné par le maire 2
l'adjointe degrés je pense que
s'instaure tout à fait tout à fait de
son père reste que la scission et bien
consommé entre les tenants de la ligne
officielle porté par alain joyandet
michel raison et les apôtres d'une
recomposition de la droite haut-saônoise
proche d'alain chrétiens dans notre
studio de besançon annie genevard
députée sortante du haut doubs nous a
rejoint lé secrétaire générale adjointe
des républicains proche de françois
fillon elle aura certainement à coeur de
commenter ce qui se passe en haute saône
mais alain chrétien on vient de vous
entendre aujourd'hui c'est clairement la
division qui vous a fait perdre
moi je ne fais la guerre à personne ces
gens là pression qu'on a tamponné
longtemps que je ne fais la guerre à
personne sauf alain joyandet
je crois que c'est plutôt l'inversé
parce que en 2015 c'est quand même lui
qui a mis quelqu'un contre ma première
adjointe à vesoul
aujourd'hui c'est quand même lui qui
conteste la légitimité du député sortant
reste c'est une très courte la candidate
souriante sortante donc moi je fais la
guerre aperçoit c'est une querelle
politique ou c'est une querelle de
personne c'est ça qui est important
je crois simplement qu alain joyandet ne
n'accepte pas que je lui ai succédé et
il essaie de mettre des croche-pieds
surtout ce qu'on fait en haute-saône
qu'on essaie de construire avec michel
réseau ours quand même c'est le front
national qui est présent dans la
circonscription puisque ils ne sont pas
très malin quand elle a quand même
envoyé l'instant parlementaire son
assistant parlementaire il ya cinq
semaines contre nous alors que la règle
chez les républicains c'est que le
député sortant a toujours droit de suite
son assistant parlementaire avait
investi son successeur eric un oui
d'ailleurs je suis déçu cani genevard
qui nous écoutent sans doute n'est pas
voté pour ma candidate alors qu'elle s'y
était engagé c'est le candidat
fillonniste qui a été investi vous payez
aussi la guerre de la présidentielle des
règlements de comptes on pêche ce
sectarisme justement demandé à nice
annie genevard comment vous vous
analyser la situation
moi je constate la violence de l'attaqué
je la déplore comme secrétaire générale
adjointe des républicains je regrette
que notre famille politique donne un tel
spectacle je voudrais dire à alain que
je connais bien nous avons siégé côte à
côte que
il faut si l'on aime sa famille comme il
vient de le dire si l'on aime sa famille
politique il faut tenir un discours de
reconstruction plutôt que d'étaler ainsi
des divisions violente j'ai rallié aux
tâches étatiques qui on voit le résultat
outils aux résultats des décisions de
paris entre 17 % et 12 % ça fait vingt
ça fait 29 % à ni si vous nous aviez
écouté s'il avait quitté le terrain
plutôt que d'écouter paris on n'en
serait pas là ma chère amie
donc je faut sans oublier le terrain et
comme tu le dis on se connaît depuis
longtemps
tu m'avais dit à condette est une bonne
candidate et deux jours plus tard tu
changes ta position non là aussi je
crois que écoute
il ya là du règlement de compte on dit
si tu ne devrais pas avoir lieu chez les
républicains
mais c'est pas de prolonger la querelle
qui te poses personnellement à tel ou
tel responsable de ton département
à mon propos ce n'est pas juste tu m'as
présente est à candidate
un autre candidat était soutenu par deux
autres parlementaires
il ya eu un arbitrage selon des selon
des règles que tu connais puisque tu en
as été en son temps le bénéficiaire
paris dit que vous ne s'est pas d'avoir
soutenu françois fillon aussi loin aussi
longtemps parce qu'on voit bien que
c'est les choix des circonscriptions et
des investitures pour les
circonscriptions aussi été guidé par ce
choix là non absolument pas absolument
pas le choix du candidat en haute saône
a été en rien guidé par l'engagement
auprès des candidats à la présidentielle
c'est tout à fait injuste et inexact de
le prétendre
notre famille politique a fait le choix
d'un candidat pour le faire gagner il
fallait s'y rallier d'autres ont quitté
très prématurément le navire août alain
tu as partie située tu as participé
comme d'autres au résultat que nous
connaissons et que je regrette
merci annie genevard pour pour cette
réaction ligne en anglais ça fait
peut-être les affaires du front national
donc non maxime thibeault d'abord
effectivement quand vous voyez ça vous
vous dites alors c'est le prolongement
de nos discussions tout à l'heure il ya
quelque chose ah non mais bon on connaît
alain joyandet on sait très bien qu'il
aime la division études à me faire
perdre son camp et en dehors de cette
considération choix marque simplement
qui a pu dit dès aujourd'hui chez les
républicains et qu'on est en train de
refaire un nouveau clivage politique
entre d'un côté les patriotes les
souverainistes et alain sincèrement si
tu veux venir tels bienvenue et de
l'autre les mondialistes
cet imprévu non mais de l'autre les
mondialistes qui sont autour de macron
et c'est un jeu il n'y a même pas de
commentaires à avoir je pense que ces
deux jeunes avaient engendré enveloppe
la parole alexandre marine parce que je
vous vois je vous vois hocher la tête
d'un air un peu dépité en voyant ce qui
se passe je suis dépité quand j'entends
plusieurs choses déjà donc on voit bien
que le spectacle qui est proposée par la
droite est déplorable on voit des
conflits de personnes qui ne parlent en
effet plus du fonds
c'est pas lui vont bien entendu mais il
ya peut-être aussi une fracture
idéologique mais c'est mieux de le
verbaliser en tout cas comme ça et moi
je suis en opposition totale avec ce que
dit et ce que dit mon voisin
le clivage aujourd'hui il est pas entre
des patriotes tous les mondialistes tout
le monde est patriote il ya aucun brevet
de patriotisme des souvenirs très bien
il ya aucun brevet de statisme affaire
pour le pour le front national ce serait
surtout du nationalisme je pense que le
21e siècle politique en tout cas est
rentré on est en plein dedans ça y est
et là par contre les trois pôles alors
justement un point réactionnaire bien
entendu qui est incarnée par l'extrême
droite mais c'est son droit c'est une
pure classe politique politicienne
or débattent à la fin c'était pas ça
comme ça en terrain politique
politicienne
tu quand tu as rejoint le front national
ni au fond d un citoyen comme tout à
leurs étudiants des jeunes on peut se
poser la question de l'abstention à ce
stade de notre émission puisque
effectivement ce qui se passe dans
l'échiquier politique peut avoir
favorisé l'abstention qui a atteint hier
des chiffres importants en bourgogne
franche comté
la mobilisation a été faible avec près
de 51% de votants soit dix points de
moins au premier tour de 2012 une
tendance encore plus marquée dans les
quartiers populaires comme on l'a
constaté à chenôve en côte d'or avec
gabrielle talon et romani rose nombre
d'électeurs votant 3597 soit 43,92
coursan ambiance morose à l'hôtel de
ville de chenôve à l'annoncé des
résultats
et l'abstention dépasse les 50 6% dans
les quartiers du mal elle atteint même
60 % dans ce quartier un peu plus tôt
dans la journée au profit de la météo
estivale les jets d'eau et promenades
ombragées attire plus que les bureaux de
vote
après avoir voté à la présidentielle
beaucoup d'électeurs ne se sont cette
fois pas rendus aux urnes
ça me sens moins important que la
présidentielle tout simplement il
faudrait peut-être plus en parler plus
sur le terrain peut-être plus venir sur
le terrain et venir avec des gens ce
n'est pas une nouveauté en 2012 déjà
l'abstention aux élections légitimes
qui était deux fois plus importante qu'à
l'élection présidentielle elle
atteignait 52 % le phénomène interpelle
et inquiète le maire de la commune
il regrette que les candidats n'aient
pas su mobiliser plus et surtout il
espère que des mesures seront prises
pour redonner de l'attrait à cette
élection aura une dose de
proportionnelle et moi j'y suis pas
personnellement favorable de se dire que
son bulletin de vote va avoir plus de
poids et que j'aurai peut-être plus de
chances d'avoir un représentant à
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'il ya une
dose de proportionnelle
vraisemblablement ce serait mobilisateur
un problème qui dépasse désormais
largement le territoire de ce nom à des
cons abstention record en ce sens pour
sélectionner annie genevard vous êtes
avec nous depuis besançon en direct
comment on fait pour mobiliser les
abstentionnistes nombreux y compris dans
votre camp certainement on l'a vu avec
les résultats entre les deux tours mais
je crois qu'il faut aller sur le terrain
bien sûr faire campagne jusqu'au dernier
moment il faut convaincre aussi les
abstentionnistes de s'impliquer parce
qu'il ya un choix majeur qui est proposé
aux français elle et les élections
législatives détermine tout de même
la couleur d'un gouvernement et la
conduite de la politique de la nation
mais au delà on sait très bien qu
emmanuel macron va vers une large
majorité les chiffres les chiffres sont
là mais l'enjeu pour nous c'est que la
droite et le centre puisse être
représenté à l'assemblée nationale
puisse porter une voix utile au pays
merci annie genevard axim thiébaut vous
qui avez aussi des candidats au second
tour en 10 secondes et mobilisez vous
n'avez pas vraiment réserves de voix
dans certaines circonscriptions
non on va mobiliser pendant aux
abstentionnistes à notre électorat
d'aller voter parce que toutes les
possibles du l'abstention et il faut une
vraie opposition à emmanuel macron dont
de voter pour les candidats front
national et vous verrons draps des élus
beaucoup plus que les que les attentes
merci merci à tous merci à tous nos
invités d'avoir participé à cette
émission spéciale merci à lilian melet
4e série de nous avoir éclairé de leur
analyse je vous rappelle que pour le
détail des résultats et toutes les
réactions en région vous pouvez vous
rendre sur notre site internet bfc point
france 3 point fr prochain rendez vous
ne le manquez pas parce qu'il sera
également beaucoup question des
élections législatives c'est bien sûr
l'information régionale à 19 heures avec
le 19/20 et d'ici là vous pouvez nous
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux facebook
et twitter france 3 bourgogne françois
franche comté très bel après midi sur
france temps
[Musique]
je